How to write code in small chunks and
test them.
Right now, nothing is on the page.
There is nothing to add on with it.
So what I would do right now,
is to actually try loading
up your game and
then put on console.log statements,
start out with console.log
inside your enemy.update
function console.log inside
your player function
just because we
are already calling them.
So as you can see Anime is
going to render all of this but
then after JS is aware it actually
runs the code and loads the resources.
And I'm thinking that you are saying
there are no enemies are bugs
inside your canvas
that is being rendered.
So what you can do is if
you don't know how to start
writing the update function,
just put in console.log.
Or what you can do is you can just
call your enemy.render function,
create an object here.
Like how I showed you how to create
var enemy equals, new enemy off.
And then you can put in the x and
y values of the enemy to just
render it on the screen.
It does not have to move it does
not have to do any functionality.
So try creating one class for
one object of the enemy.
And try calling the render
function on it.
That should be very helpful
console log is very useful so
use a lot of prince statements around.
Since i know that inside engine.js.
You will be calling enemy.update and
enemy.renderfunction here.
You will obviously need these
functions defined inside your app and
your as a file.
>> I wanted to make a green bug, so I
went into Photoshop and altered the hue.
But I get this error.
Failed to execute draw image on
canvas rendering context 2D.
The provided value is not of
type HTML image element, or
HTML video element or
HTML canvas element.
>> Okay, so as long as you
save it in a PNG format, and
put it inside your images repository
it shouldn't have a problem.
I have known a lot of students actually
putting in different colors to the bug.
Blue, yellow, green, and
all that they have to do
is Photoshop the images just saving
inside your images repository.
And then adding to your resources.
So, wherever I think sure change
you inside one of your gs finals.
I believe it is your engine.js file.
Make sure that you
are morons are right here.
You can see that you are loading all
these and you have only enemy-bug.png.
Wait, you can name it yellow-bug,
blue-bug, whatever color you set it in.
But make sure you add it
into the road function and
make sure it isn't
your images repository.
As long as you're doing that,
it should work.
>> I'm trying to code for P 3 to detect
collision, but when i make every
from the enemy.x may creating var.enemy.
Experimenting equal to
the enemy.x minus fifty I get
an undefined because my
enemy dot X was only 34.
Thus I got a negative number.
Please let me know how to avoid this.
>> Okay, well good question kid.
This part of the project is very tricky.
Now, it surprises me a little bit that
you get an undefined error because these
are in the jurors and so
subtracting them should just.
Result in the worst case as a negative
number which might be off your canvas
but what I do have is a great link and
so this page as you can check it out it
talks of it tells you here exactly
about axis-aligned bounding box.
And what you can do for
it to test your collisions.
I don't think you have to worry about
circle collision, but just this top one
here, axis-aligned bounding box,
should be enough to get you started.
The other thing to think about too is
you can think about collision
as in the reverse sense.
So, you can think about you could write
a function to say what are you not
colliding.
And then say what do
you not not colliding.
That can actually be easier
math than facts and times.
So if that's at all helpful,
give that whirl.
If you are having questions
about your specific code and
this website doesn't help and
the different way of thinking about it
in terms of doing the opposite
of not collide doesn't help.
Please post a question to
the discussions and either us or
one of the students can try to
help look at your exact code
to see what's going on there.
>> P 3 is there anything we should set
up for when get an answer user close.
We know to clear memory allocations.
No so this is the beauty of JavaScript.
It has automatic garbage collection and
this is a constant and
more low level programming languages
such as C, C++ plus or even Java.
Is that like, the language itself,
JavaScript automatically
clears the memory for
you like if you have an object.
And if the object is not being
referenced by anything then the computer
of the job.
The language itself, JavaScript is
smart enough to know that okay,
there's nothing that's referencing
this object anymore in my memory.
I'm just going to
automatically clear it.
And you don't have to deal
with garbage collection.
Unlike a low level programming
language like C, C++.
>> What goes in the index.html file?
It appears you have the canvas
drawn from in the engine.js file.
Is this a place to build
a custom background, thanks.
>> So the index.html file, you
shouldn't have to add anything to it.
If you wanted to, maybe let's say
you wanted to have like a title
If you could but if your custom
background you're referring to.
If you want to custom background for
your game kind of like a backdrop
yeah you could edit the CSS and put like
a background image on your body tag.
But if your background you're
referring to is the game level,
then you would need to
edit that in engine.js.
>> Yeah, I mean there should you
shouldn't have to touch the HTML or
CSS files.
>> Multi pass.
>> Yeah if you want to do something.
>> Yeah.
>> Cool then you have to
play with them a little bit.
>> I'm trying to figure out
the with the height of players and
bugs images are 101 by 171 pixels.
But that is not how tall a white
the bugging players are.
Is there a way to figure this out?
I'm working on collusion and
trying to define the rectangles.
So actually the suit really good
question and it was something that I
initially had a little bit of trouble
with i like what my player on the board.
He ended up kind of police sort
of off the board a little bit.
And I kind of played around
with the measurements until
they got good on there.
And then I realized like my bugs were
hitting my player at these weird angles,
and I was just like, all right.
I've just gotta figure
out how big these are.
So do you have a tip for figuring out,
sort of, the size of the players and
the bugs?
>> I'll tell you the reason
it's weird like that,
Is because it kind of looks
like a top down game.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But it's really not.
If you look at the very bottom row.
It's a square.
But then it has that.
You see.
>> Yeah.
>> The front of the square.
Right?
So what happens is when
the squares are drawn there.
The top layer is drawn.
>> Mm-hm?
>> And then the.
>> At the top row drawn,
and the second row is drawn on top
of that bottom piece a little bit.
So, they're oddly stacked.
I would say that the player and
the bugs should be sized as to
the top of those images and not look
what the white actual images kind of
ignore that bottom little piece there.
What I did in my implementation was
actually defined an object that said
row one is this Y coordinate
Row two is this Y coordinate.
And then I use that object of
okay my player is on row one and
my bugs are on row one.
So that's now I can actually
work on collision and stuff.
It is weird, the math can get odd.
For some reason 73 is in my head.
I think that was my [LAUGH]
73 pixels was my number.
>> I don't know what
mine ended up being.
I think mind ended up being like 30 or
80 or something.
I don't remember.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah.
It was one of those things that, I mean,
it really did just take trial and error.
>> Yeah.
>> To get it right.
But I guess that's kind
of part of making a game.
kind of shuffling things a little
bit until they fit together.
>> Yeah.
So what I eventually did was I created
a step size variable for the player.
So I said any time I press up,
he's going to move
vertically this much space.
And then I would just constantly be i
would have just that I would step that's
like sixty pixels and then i reload
the game and president of up.
And if it looked like he was staying
in the center of the blocks of.
Boxes all the way up.
Then i had the right number.
If he was going too far or not far
enough and i just did that number.
And then i did the same thing with
watched her back steps you know.
Horizontal and.
Just Tweaked it and played with it.
It didn't take long.
>> [CROSSTALK] Yeah.
>> I mean once I just,
because I did the same thing as you.
I was trying to just
handle these images.
And so, I mean,
I did the same thing as you.
I tried to think about it logically and
define it and, it really did for
me, just become a practice of all
right just define a number and
tweak it and figure it out.